Johnson and Johnson it may be causing  cancer it is alleged that the taco based  powder that is Iconic to their baby  powder is actually contaminated with  asbestos the obvious reasoning for this  is that the minds in which taka's mind  are often lined with asbestos so it's  only natural that the talc is also  contaminated with asbestos but it was  assumed that J J had procedures and  protocols in place to ensure that  asbestos wouldn't show up in the final  product J and J of course insist that  they do indeed have such procedures in  place and they deny all allegations but  this didn't stop 40 000 cancer patients  whose cancer may have been caused by  asbestos from bending together and find  lawsuits against the jnj and the  evidence that surfaced since then is  disturbing it to say the least